ANDRE: The boys are back.
Today we're talking about
Sam and Bucky, aka
Marvel Studios' "The Falcon
and The Winter Soldier."
I'm Andre.
And I'm Jenny.
This is "What's Up,
Disney+," where
we talk all things Disney+.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Lorraine Cink is a senior
creative producer and host
of the Marvel Entertainment
YouTube channel,
and we are very thrilled
to have her here with us
today. Lorraine, welcome
to "What's Up, Disney+."
Hey, Jenny, Andre, I'm so
excited to find out what's up.
Well, glad to have you here.
We know that you are
a huge Marvel fan.
So how did you get into that?
Well, like a lot
of kids, I learned
to read by reading
comics, and I just
fell in love with super heroes.
And it's become a
lifelong passion.
And now I've worked for
Marvel for 10 years,
written three books, and hosted
a whole lot of red carpets.
That's amazing.
All right, Lorraine, we thought
who better to help us catch up
for Marvel Studios' "The
Falcon and The Winter Soldier"
than yourself?
Oh yeah, on your left.
Let's do it.
Well, I'm glad you're ready,
because a lot has happened
to these two characters
throughout the course
of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe,
and we want to
catch everybody up.
But, Lorraine, we like to
challenge ourselves here
on "What's Up, Disney+,"
so we're going to try
to recap it in record time.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am ready.
I am channeling
all my superspeed.
All right then, let's do it.
In the Marvel
Cinematic Universe,
Bucky first appears
as Steve Rogers
bestie from Brooklyn, James
Buchanan Barnes, or Bucky
for short.
Bucky went off to fight
in World War II, where
he reconnected with Steve,
now as Captain America,
while they tried to take
down a Hydra base in Austria.
While Cap is victorious,
Bucky is thrown off a train
and thought to be dead.
Fast forward years later,
when Sam and Cap become
close as fellow
veterans who lost a best
friend in the line of duty.
LORRAINE CINK: So when
S.H.I.E.L.D. is infiltrated by
Hydra, Sam gives Cap and Black
Widow a place to lay low.
Which gets even more complicated
when an assassin starts hunting
them, named the Winter Soldier.
When he and Cap finally
come face to face,
he is revealed to be Bucky.
That's right, he's alive.
But his memory has been
wiped and modified by Hydra.
Cap, Black Widow, and Sam
battle the Winter Soldier,
but Steve doesn't have the heart
to take out his best friend.
An unconscious Cap
falls to the water below,
and Bucky, regaining a
fragment of his former self,
dives in to save Steve.
Then after, he leaves him on
the shore and disappears.
During Marvel
Studios' "Age of Ultron"
Bucky is nowhere to be seen.
But Sam does get an upgrade,
including a heroic costume
when the Avengers
expand their ranks
after the Battle of Sokovia.
At the resulting
Sokovia Accords,
a bomb is detonated seemingly
by Bucky Barnes, which
kills the Wakandan
King, T'Chaka,
and his son, T'Challa,
pledges to kill Bucky himself.
Captain America and Sam Wilson
head out to bring in Bucky.
However, it turns
out Bucky was framed.
Bucky, now in Winter Soldier
mode, beats Sam and escapes.
Cap stops Bucky
and saves his life,
like Bucky once did for him.
So when Sam and Bucky are
reunited on the same team,
Sam is not a huge fan of
Bucky who tried to assassinate
all of his best friends.
During the epic showdown, Team
Cap and Team Iron Man face off,
and Bucky and Sam
manage to work together,
despite bickering like
an old married couple.
I hate you.
Zemo is revealed to be the
bomber, clearing Bucky's name,
and Team Cap goes after him.
Ultimately, Cap seeks
asylum in Wakanda,
where Bucky is put on ice to
remove his HydrA programming.
Poor Sam Wilson, unfortunately,
is locked up at the Raft
with the other Avengers.
In Marvel Studios'
"Avengers: Infinity War"
we see Sam has been released and
allowed to rejoin the Avengers,
who take on Thanos.
Bucky and Sam reunite
back in Wakanda,
battling the children of Thanos
and their army of Outriders.
Then in a snap they're gone,
and we won't see them again
on anyone's left until they're
brought back later through Dr.
Strange's magic portals in the
epic final battle of Marvel
Studios' "Avengers: Endgame."
I love that part.
After all the dust clears,
a much-older Captain America
is revealed to have used the
quantum suit to go back in time
and return all of
the Infinity Stones.
Bucky looks on as
Captain America
passes the shield to Sam.
[BELL RINGING]
- Woo!
Woo!
We did it!
What a journey that those
two characters have been on,
and what a journey we
just went through trying
to recap all of it.
Before you go, Lorraine,
can you tell us
what we can expect
coming up on the Marvel
Entertainment YouTube channel?
Yeah, you can
check out everything
in the Marvel universe.
We're going to have
some cool stuff,
I'm sure, coming up for
Marvel Studios' "The Falcon
and The Winter Soldier."
Then, also go back and check
out some of the cool stuff
we created around Marvel
Studios' "WandaVision."
I mean, it's all there.
Just go-- go check it out.
Well, thank you
so much, Lorraine,
for recapping this as quickly
as possible with Andre and I.
We can't thank you enough.
You are awesome.
Oh my gosh, you
guys are awesome.
You did so well with all
of that Marvel universe,
because it is a lot,
let me tell you.
Thank you so much for having me.
And now, here's what's new.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY: Break the fourth wall
of Marvel Studios' "WandaVision"
with Marvel Studios' "Assembled:
The Making of WandaVision,"
an original special now
streaming on Disney+.
ANDRE: This April come
back down to earth.
"Earth Moods," an
original series
from National
Geographic, is streaming
April 16 on Disney+.
JENNY: In collaboration
with First Book,
Disney is celebrating
the magic of storytelling
by helping to cultivate the
next generation of storytellers
and providing books to educators
who serve kids in need.
Hear from some of your
favorite Disney+ stars
and learn more at
MagicOfStorytelling.com.
Now we get to
hear from Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan.
Take a look.
I'm Sebastian Stan.
And I'm Anthony
Mackie, and we are
the stars of Marvel
Studios' "The Falcon
and The Winter Soldier."
We are going to have
a compiment showdown.
Where do we start?
Sebastian, you
have wonderful hair.
OK, well you have
such a big heart that's
protected by a lot of strength.
Sebastian, your personality
would make a grown man smile.
The walls that you have
will protect me forever.
You make me so happy I want
to sit in your lap and cuddle.
No couch will ever be as
firm and soft as your thighs.
You're like, the goose
down of beautiful people.
You're warm and inviting.
I will always walk into
your shadow if I have to.
I'll be the man who
will fight for your honor.
We don't need any
other heroes but you.
There's no way on Earth
that we could wake up
and it not be a sunny
day without thinking
of the face of Sebastian Stan.
I want to remake every
romantic comedy with you.
You, my friend, are the
scrambled eggs to my omelet.
Oh my god.
[BELL RINGING]
I think I won.
We were great.
Stream Marvel Studios' "The
Falcon and The Winter Soldier"
tomorrow on Disney+.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We heard from Lorraine
Cink, and the cast
and crew of Marvel Studios' "The
Falcon and The Winter Soldier."
I don't know about you, Andre,
but I'm ready for action.
Right there with you, Jenny.
Well, that's it for today.
Make sure you go over to
Disney+ and stream
all of your favorites, and
we'll see you next week.
All right, Andre,
staring contest.
3, 2, 1, go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And I blinked.
[LAUGHING]
Just blink.
[MUSIC PLAYING]